the Joe Rogan experience so while
there's some other good fights that
happened this weekend oh dude how bout
those on just vs. Kevin Lee um I didn't
see a bro it's up easy again I was at
the wilder fight I missed that I notice
on just look good and be Kevin Lee needs
a new camp Kevin Lee needs a camp yeah
yeah I think Kevin Lee should go to
forest a hobby that's my advice or
Jackson's well the reason why for us a
hobby is because Kevin Lee skill set is
very similar to George st. Pierre's in
striking Leduc very athletic impressive
and grounding timing of his takedowns
nobody knows how to coach that better
than Frost's army it's a good idea yeah
it's not bad at all
that's what I think Hooton Pico just
went to Jackson's yes I think that's a
great move too you know oh yeah I hooked
him up with my boy Vinnie Norman too
so I I told him that I think that he
should go to frost hobbies and I told
him about Vinnie Sherman who's an
incredible mental coach you know he's
gonna be champ I believe if he gets a
[ __ ] together and goes to a legit camp
because you remember his coach passed
away right yeah and I told us who was
very close to such a shame amazing
amazing guy and so he passed away and
then it was like he was like I'll just
stay here and put together this kind of
ragtag group and we'll figure it out at
the the UFC now is it such a high level
to compete with the guys he's competing
with you gotta have a good camp man like
a legit yeah ouch head coach leader it's
no disrespect to any of small camps or
small gyms no I'm not I'm not trying to
be I'm just saying that an athlete has a
small [ __ ] window man like Kevin is
26 right so he's got ten years it's long
why it's three out of his last four yeah
not good UFC don't play with that
and before that I'm just a PFA leading
guys in pretty spectacular fashion right
Robert folds his death had a tremendous
impact on him as a fighter as a person
and then he fought some really great
fighters too on top of that you know and
a like went oh man I mean from the jump
of that fight from the the get-go and he
hit him with that spinning backfist you
let him know like this is you're in a
dogfight I said that Tony forget fight
was a dog fight a dog fight a dog fight
yeah these guys have dog fights and when
the Tony Ferguson fight he had a staph
infection clear a hundred percent and he
looked good twenty
I was going down I choked out God is
[ __ ] ahead man look when you
have you've had staff before right yeah
that's awful and the way it drains our
body drains your body well the staff
does too
I mean if you get it - as far as where
it is with him he's in a full infection
he has a full infection so it's in his
bloodstream but the thing that [ __ ]
your cardio and your energy like no
other in the antibiotics [ __ ] you so but
they do but so does the staff especially
when it's that bad I mean he's got a
[ __ ] a giant squirrel growing out of
his tit remember that what he told DC
nuts and that's I saw it immediately he
walked in the Octagon I'm like he's got
staph I got that stabbed I say hey DC I
go is that staff that looks like staff
to me and they go do not talk about the
staff he goes that looks like staff to
me Joe he doesn't give a lot of them
like [ __ ] you're talking to Daniel
Cormier you can tell me when you talk
about Sugano staff better anyone that
got here it's he's a wrestling coach
listen we would be doing a massive
disservice to the viewing public if we
didn't admit that it was staff it's a
fart it's part of the drama it's part of
what makes the fights interesting but my
take on Kevin Lee is he's a great guy I
really I'm gonna have him on again he's
gonna come on against the best he's a
great person I like talking to mark
because I'll put him on the food truck
diary okay he's great I'll text you
about two shots with you what arrow nod
or about it but anyway I visit there's a
defining moment in a fighter's career
when they realize they need to make
changes they're not doing things the way
they should be doing them and they need
to make some change but but I think one
of the reasons why you care and I care
especially with Kevin if it was somebody
else some other guys won't mention names
but with Kevin I go well no he can be
champ you just have to change a few
things you see this kid's champion the
other kind of nice badge to keep doing
what you do he hundred one hundred
percent is the skills the mindset name
he has the full package he looks good
speaks good dress as well has the skills
sign me up he's a good person too we
talk when you talk to him he's gonna
feel it yeah he's just gotta make some
changes and he needs a Mastro he needs a
[ __ ] conductor he needs a Greg Jack
you can't get those out of these days
Duke Rufus
[Applause]